In a real world scenario,
health system vendors usually create Fire resources from data stored
in a proprietary database designed and built before Fire existed.
When a Fire app or a REST API ask for a resource,
special software often called a Fire adapter or server must know how to
get data elements from that database and package them into the Fire resource format.
The data that populates that Fire resource will therefore
depend on the underlying system.
If that system stores clinical observations only as text,
then even though Fire specifies them,
LOINC codes will not be available in the Fire resources that system creates.
Alternately, the design is so the Fire adapter
might make the effort to add any missing codes.
In either case, there is no assurance that
different EHRs represent or code a concept the same way.
Many major healthcare enterprise software vendors including Epic, Cerner and Meditech,
the three most widely installed,
have released at least a preliminary Fire server,
sometimes with integrated support for the Smart and Fire applet form.
We will look at the examples of this later on.
Finally, again at present,
most vendor support is for the reading of resources.
Support for the rest of CRUD is more difficult for vendors to implement
because of the need to verify the various checks and safeguards used in their systems.
This will come later if at all.
HL7 maintains a web page that summarizes the ever growing list of
health IT system vendors and
other organizations interested in Fire along with a link to their site,
contact information and a brief description of their intended use of the standard.